hello this is Matthew from simply
learned and in this video we're gonna
take you through the 10 most popular
tools that you'll need to have in your
dev ops setup what I'm going to do is
we're going to break it up the tools
into eight different categories I'm
going to go through the planning and
code base tools the building tools the
testing tools the all-important
integration tool the deployment
operation and then finally monitoring
tools something we should also add is
that all of these tools are open-source
this means that you can get up and
running with your DevOps environments
immediately without having to worry
about licensing costs so let's jump into
the very first tool which is get so git
is a distributed version control tool
that allows development teams to be able
to share code amongst each other in a
way that allows the creation of small to
extremely large applications to be
created effortlessly if we look at the
architecture of given the way that it
works that there are four key areas we
have the working directory the staging
area a local repository and then remote
repository so your working directory is
where you actually create all the files
that you'd be working on in your
application and the staging is the area
that you get to ready to commit those
files to your local repository for
version control and once you actually
have then put them into your local
repository then you want to be able to
push those files using a push command
out to a remote repository such as
github or get lab in addition if you
have a distributed team but you can then
also then pull down the latest files so
as a team you can always be working on
all the files all the time and then go
through the whole process again by
working on your local files you can do
this whole process really quickly and
easily get is actually a free tool you
can download and run through command
line off your computer finally you want
to be able to merge files that you may
be working on say for instance a
different branch which is a new feature
and you want to be able merge those
files back into the master directory the
master branch that's running on git
itself so some of the things to point
out with get what makes it really useful
is that it's absolutely brilliant at
being able to track changes in your
source code this is something that
source code tools do I really kind of
should be able to do but
it is accepting good at this having
large teams working at different phases
within the project and working on
different branches within the project is
really easy to do and the collaboration
tools within get to make aids so that
your teams can work effortlessly with
each other
inherently you are creating backups of
all your code which is fantastic and
probably most important part is that the
environment itself is a nonlinear
environment this means that you don't
have to work through specific gates to
be able to reach feature to actually get
a feature ready for delivery you can
actually work in a nonlinear fashion so
who's using gate wires you can imagine
all of the big technology companies are
using gates including Netflix left and
empower plus many many other companies
so let's get on to our next tool which
is mavin and the focus on mavin is to
automate the build process of code
that's been checked into a repository
such as a kit repository so we have a
look at the architecture here mavin
itself actually executes what are called
pom files and those pom files actually
then look for specific dependencies that
will then go against a repository to be
able to build out the project you can
actually extend the pom files with
plugins and you can't you then create a
specific build profile for your
environments which is absolutely
fantastic because you can really
fine-tune the profile and again all this
is scripted and this is something that
is common with all the tools that you'll
be using in a true DevOps environment is
that you can script all of them which
means that you can automate the
processes that are in your DevOps
environment and it really accelerates
the ability to be able to build
consistent high quality software final
step 4 and mavin rhyming strategy build
all the software into a you know a build
server so a couple of things that are
important to notice with mavin and one
of the things that you'll see it's key
with all of the tools that we have here
really easy to use mavin itself it's got
a pretty simple set up but it's highly
available which means that your team can
rely on the solution being ready for
your environment and you can actually
get to it and use it very easily and
consistently you can have multiple
builds happening at the same time which
is really important particularly if you
have branched software you want to be
able to test the branches and the other
thing as well is that it's open source
so you have instant access to new
features without any additional
configuration so it really
helps your teams to get the new code and
implement new features within the
environment itself so you're always
working on the latest and greatest as
you can imagine DevOps shops such as
Zillow and Zen's aren't JP Morgan Chase
are already using mavin and you'll see
that many DevOps shops are also using
them and for their build software
testing with selenium is very important
and being able to automate that
environment is critical so you can
actually guarantee that your code will
work and selenium itself is designed for
testing and automating web applications
it's really good in that environment and
we look at the architecture the way that
it works is that you actually have a
client library that goes against the
code you're writing with a c-sharp
Python Java JavaScript and then there
are specific drivers that go against the
web browsers to actually test out the
code that you have created so that you
can actually see whether it works in the
appropriate web browsers and all of the
popular web browsers are supported with
selenium selenium is an open source
solution it does allow you to write
scripts in multiple different languages
which is a real big bonus you can as
well run parallel test execution so this
browser is very well with mavin and as
with other tools that we have it's
really easy to use and selenium is being
used by Google HubSpot and Salesforce as
well as many other companies so let's
talk about the really important part
which is integrating all of this and
Jenkins really is the de-facto tool in
this space so the role of Jenkins is to
be able to merge and allow for that
continuous integration that you need to
make DevOps successful so allowing the
dev the development team to integrate
effectively with the ops the operations
team and do that through testing and
management of the code that has been
created
so if we look at the architecture here
we have our remote source code
repository it's going to be waiting for
a Jenkins pull to be able to create a
commit and then that Jenkins surf master
will then push out and distribute the
work to multiple slaves so that you
actually have the actual code being
pushed around your environment so
Jenkins is really easy to use it's very
mature it's been around for many years
there are a significant number of
plugins that allowed for the Jenkins
environment to be scaled very
effectively and it is portable across
multiple platforms
in fact most of the leading operating
systems will support Jenkins and as you
can imagine
Jenkins is being used by companies such
as LinkedIn and Microsoft eBay Dowell
and cloud era so let's talk about the
other side of DevOps
and talk about some of the operations
tool and we'll start off with darker so
the role of docker is to make it easy
for people to be able to simulate full
environments quickly and easily on their
desktop for building and testing but at
the same time make it real easy to be
able to port those environments across
multiple areas so let's let me talk a
little bit about how that would work so
with the doctor engine you have a docker
client locally that allows you to
emulate the whole docker environment
without having to have the overhead that
you would typically have if you're doing
virtualization or dedicated servers
range specific dedicated operating
systems because you are scripting the
entire environment doctor is a very
scalable and repeatable environment for
being able to take across the entire
cloud network so some of the features
are really important for doctor it's
incredibly portable across multiple
platforms the doctor team we've done a
fantastic job on portability it does run
in isolation so what this means is that
you can actually have multiple doctor
environments running on a server
concurrently and they will not interrupt
each other they actually fully isolated
sandbox environments so the other part
to doctors because it is stripped of
needless operating system and and host
environments api's and services the
actual startup and boot time for a doc
is really very fast which in turn makes
this very scalable and efficient to run
and you can actually reuse volumes very
easily so who's using docker just about
everybody
Spotify uber PayPal BBC really docker is
used by a lot of people just as I know
probably something that would compliment
go very well is kubernetes and
kubernetes is becoming a very popular
and so you know really get to know both
of those tools
so let's talk about some of the
operation and management and tools that
you have for your environments and the
three big ones here are chef hands bowl
and puppet and we'll start with ansible
and ansible is a configuration software
package and unlike the other two
products here unlike chef and puppet and
so it doesn't actually require a
client's to run on the host server where
you're pushing out a configuration
you know actually have a defined
operation configuration so like a web
server configuration or a database
configuration or an iot-cloud
configuration you can if you have that
run income effectively from a script
that is written on a client machine and
then on your local machine and then you
can push that script you've created out
to your remote and servers and have
everything work as you'd expect quickly
on your remote servers you know just
some of the key features of an support
it's incredibly lightweight it's one of
the things that's really important with
as well is that it's actually a very
easy easy to use there is unlike the
other two tools we'll be covering
unlike puppet and chef ansible actually
has a full GUI that you can use to
actually interact and build out
solutions so there is a a visual
interface that you can actually go in so
you're not just working completely in
command-line companies that are using
ansible include twitter EA Sports Cisco
and NASA's was a Verizon so
complementing and small about probably a
little bit more popular right now our
chef and puppet and we'll cover chef
first I both chef and puppet are
somewhat similar in configuration and
both of them rely on having a
client-server relationship with their
architecture the way that chef works is
that chef fetch Sydney creates recipes
and they each recipe is a server
configuration setup and what you
actually do is you create individual
recipes and then for your entire network
you create what's called a cookbook and
that cookbook actually can be used to
control the setup of your entire network
and this works really well for being
able to create consistent and highly
scalable environments things are great
with chef is that it's actually a very
flexible configuration and you can
an awful lot with it has really good
security features which are very
appealing to particularly if you have a
dev sac ops environment with security
team power integrated with your DevOps
environment and that's something that's
becoming more and more popular chef it's
actually pretty easy to use there's a
command-line tool but it is actually
fairly easy to use and the actual
scripting of the recipes is something
that you can do even if you don't have
much scripting experience is something
there are so many recipes out and
available you can actually use many of
the templates are all being written and
just either copy them or modify them to
your environment as you'd expect a lot
of the companies are using chef are the
big technology companies such as
Facebook an IBM Microsoft in particular
has really invested heavily and chef but
you'll find that chef is probably the
most popular management tool used within
the Asha environment so a complementary
product to chef is puppet and if we look
at puppets and as you can imagine it
again another open source configuration
tool the structure as you can see is
actually very similar in concept to a
chef in which you have a local server
that actually has all the configuration
environments the templates and the files
and the manifests and it will actually
then communicate with all of your entire
environments such as and with puppet
they refer to them as nodes and within
your node you have multiple servers but
it's similar in concept to chef in many
ways and that it's just another way of
being able to control your environment
both are really great tools in fact
really all three of them as well chef
and puppet are great tools what you have
to do as a DevOps team is really just
decide which tool is the one that's
appropriate for your environment so some
things are great with puppet it's a
multi-platform compatible it's very
scalable and allows you to push out
changes to your environment really
really fast and who are using puppets
you know got bright hat HP Google
leading dev ops teams are using puppets
today so let's get into the two tools
that we have that actually monitor our
operations environments Punk and they
goes so Splunk
is as expected is a monitoring tool and
its goal is to actually monitoring the
operations of all the environments you
have to make sure that they're working
correctly and it does this by going
through and reviewing your entire
environment and writing the operational
information to disk and then searching
that environment to make sure everything
works correctly it does a lot of
analysis in real time it is a very easy
to setup a new tool for testing for
analysis and then be able to then
troubleshoot any failures that may come
up the thing that's great about spunk is
that you can actually put it in a
distributed environment so that's no
single point of failure which makes it
itself inherently very very scalable so
Cisco Facebook Domino's Pizza Dubai
Airports are all customers that are
using Splunk today in their DevOps
environments so finally let's jump into
our final monitoring tool which is
Niguel and very similar to spunk is
Negus only the big difference is its
client-server setup but really again
it's all about being able to monitor and
check the status of your entire
environment and your network and your
servers in real-time and give you the
appropriate visualizations with it's on
your laptop or whether it's an alert
that sent out to your phone and you know
so you're aware in real-time how your
network is performing and can then check
and adjust to actually making changes in
the bottom line in this kind of
architecture with Splunk and Megos is
that it allows you as the operations
leads to be able to be ahead of any
perceived impact so say for instance you
are putting in specific check marks for
your environment you can actually have
alerts being sent out to your team when
certain thresholds are met and so that
means that you are aware of problems
with your environment before your
customer is there's nothing worse than
somebody emailing and saying hey your
website doesn't work or like a page is
down or it's slow or something like this
with Nagios and Splunk these are tools
that really address those kind of
problems so that you stay ahead of the
curve so some of the things that are
really good with Negus Negus itself is
very very comprehensive you can do an
awful lot with it and it allows you to
be able to
get to the root of monitoring and allies
in your problems within your operations
in network environment very quickly it
has a very modular architecture which
also then makes it extremely highly
available and because the the system
itself is not reliant on just a single
large application actually the modular
architecture allows it to be scalable
and very easy to imagine tight
environment companies using an iOS
include uber and hike and web idea again
these are all technology companies but
there's no reason why you should be
using them as well so hopefully you've
enjoyed our 10 tools that you need
within your DevOps environment to help
cover both the dev the ops and the
integration between dev and ops we also
snuck in a couple of extra bonuses in
there as well as talking a little bit
about dev sack ops which is really the
evolution of DevOps if you have any
additional tools you think that we
missed that we should have had in this
list please put those in the comments
below and again as always if you have
any questions put your questions below
in the comments and we'll get back to
you with answers from our simply learned
team this has been Matthew are giving
you a quick overview of the top 10 tools
and dev ops have a brilliant day
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here